دعوتهم لتظاهرات واسعه في ايران اليوم
ونظام يعدم اكثر من 500 شخص منذ مطلع
العام
قوى سياسيه سودانيه توقع اليوم على اتفاق
ايطالي لحل الازمه وتشكيل سلطه الانتقاليه
مدنيه
والبسيطه
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله مشاهدينا الكرام اهلا بكم معنا
الى هذه النشره المفصله تاتيكم من العربيه
اعلنت منظمه حقوق الانسان الايرانيه عن
اعدام اكثر من 500 شخص في البلاد منذ
بدايتها هذا العام وقالت المنظمه في بيان
ان هذا اعلمه
في ايران خلال خمس سنوات مشيره الى تنفيذ
السلطات الايرانيه لحكم الاعدام في اربعه
اشخاص في وقت سابقا الامس في سجن رجائي
شهر بمدينه كرش غربي العاصمه طهران التي
تتعلق بتعاون مع الاستخبارات الاسرائيليه
ادوات تستمر موجه دعوات للمشاركه الواسعه
في تظاهرات شديده طريق اليوم الاثنين
وتستمر حتى السابع من الشهر الجاري تحت
شعار انتفاضه ديسمبر ومن الموز مع تنظيم
احتجاجت اليوم او في اليوم الذي من المقرر
ان يلقي الرئيس ابراهيم رئيسي كلمه امام
الطلاب في جامعه طهران يوم الاربعاء
المقبل
[موسيقى]
فصولي
ا ازادي هاي داي
[موسيقى]
من المتوقع ان توقع القوه السياسيه في
السودان اليوم على الاتفاق الايطالي
لانهاء الازمه السياسيه
سلطه الانتقاليه مدنيه وفق مجلس السياده
الانتقالي وقوه الحريه والتغيير
من الشعب السوداني مرفوضه من الكتله
الديموغرافيه
ومعالجان المقاومه مع كل الاحزاب السياسيه
مع كل المواطنين
وسوف نقاوم هذه الاتفاقيه وهذا الاتفاقيه
فقط تكتب على ورق لكنها ان شاء الله لم
تقوم لها قائمه لن يكتب لها النجاح وان
احنا نضل نعمل ضدها وضد وكل مخرجاته
الاعتبار انه ثورتنا دي امام طالبه ثورتنا
هي مطالبه على راسها ازاله كامله للنظام
المباد هذه التسويه ستقود الى استمرار
نظام نبات الى حين اعاده انقضاضه مره اخرى
بشكل افظع من شكل 20 اكتوبر الاتفاق
الايطالي ما عنده اي مستقبل في البلد لا
يمكن تطبيقه في البلد وهو ساقط لا محاله
اذا تم هو تطور لان شكل الحكومه وهيشكل
حكومه هزيله ضعيفه وما عندها مستقبل
وبالتالي ده تضييع لزمان الشعب السوداني
واهدار طريقه نواحي الطريقه المقاومه واحد
طريق الصور واحد هي التطهير الجماهيري
والعمل المقاوم من اجل اسقاط يعني الطقم
الانقلابيه وكل من ينخرط معه في هذه
التسويه او في التسوياتهم كلهم هم اعداء
الثوره وكلهم هذا الشعب السوداني وخط
الحديد السوداني التغيير
في منه انه هم ماجد رئيس ابعدوا برهان ولا
قدر يستبعدوا هميتي ده معنا جنود ده معنى
انه لازل عن المجلس العسكري هو الغابط ده
بمعنى انه التكرار بتاع سيناريو بتاعه
مجلس السياده اللي كان قالوا لنا في
الغيارين انه مجلس سياره مجلسي وفي
النهايه الفتره الانتقاليه كله لقينا انه
المجلس بتاعه الوزراء والحكومه المدنيه
اللي بيتكلموا عنه هو الحكومه الشرفيه
فيما يتعلق
بالتفاقه المجمع التوقيع عليه وغدا حزب
البحث عن العربي الاشتراكي يجدد التمسكه
باسقاط الانقلاب ويجدد رفضه لهذا الاتفاق
لانه شرعا للانقلاب ويعوم الحريه والتغيير
في بحيره من قوه النظام المباد والفنون
ولن نكون جزءا منه ولا انه واقع عليه
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
محاكمه عشره
مطار ومترو بروكسل تنطلق اليوم في بلجيكا
اهلا بكم من جديد دخل قرار الاتحاد
الاوروبي ودول مجموعه السبع واستراليا حضر
استيراد النفط الروسيه
للبرميل دخل حيزه تنفيذ فيما حضر النائب
رئيس الوزراء الروسيه
لن تصدر الخامه الخاضع للصف ثريا فرضه
الغرب وقال نوفاكنه تحرك الغرب هو تدخل
سافر ينافي قواعد تجاره الحره
استقرار اسواق الطاقه العالميه اضفنا
روسيا تعمل على وضعيه لحظر استخدام سقف
سريع بصرف النظر عن المستوى المحدد وانا
ستبيعه ومنتجات البترول فقط الى الدول
التي ستعمل معها بموجب بموجب ظروف السوق
انا رئيس الوكراني فاقد حذر من محاوله
القوات الروسيه استغلال البرد القارس
والشتاء كجزء من رعبها
ومؤكدا ان القوات الاوكرانيه ستفعل ما
بوسعها للبقاء صامده في مواجهه كل هذه
التحديات
نا ولكننا سنفعل كل ما في وسعنا للبقايا
على قيد الحياه بغض النظر عن مدى صعوبه
ذلك ادعمونا
وسنتمكن من تخطي هذا الشتاء لروسيا
صواريخها ومدفعياتها ولكنها لا تملك ما
لدينا فنحن نحمي بيوتنا وندافع عن ارضنا
وهذا يعطينا اقوى دافع ممكن
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه انا قوتها
نفذت عمليه هجوميا ناجحه قرب دونات مؤكده
مقتل اكثر من 50 جنديا اوكرانيا وتدميرها
ست مدرعات في تلك المناطق كما اكدت وزاره
الدفاع في بيان لها مقتل 200 جندي اوكراني
في محاولات هجوم فاشله على عده محاور لا
سيما على محاور تونس الشماليه والجنوبيه
ومحور كوبي يا ناسك الشمال
التقارير استخباراتيه على احتماليه اطالته
حرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه الى ما بعد الشتاء
في ظل استعدادا في ظل استعدادات من كل
جانب لاعادته تجهيزه قوته وانجازها
بالمعدات العسكريه اللازمه وسطا حصار
الاعمال القتاليه في مصر شرقي اوكرانيا
ميدان الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه يقف على
جانبيه طرف الصراع واختبار فصل الشتاء لم
يحسن بعد ومع دخول النساء شهره الحادي عشر
تنحصر الاعمال القتاليه في محيط مناطق
باخبط ودونيستك شرقيه اوكرانيا فيما يعيد
كل جانب حسابات اعاده التجهيز العسكري
وشحن الامداد وتنظيم تحركاته العسكريه
صوره تعكس طول امد الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه وان لم تغيب عنها مشاهد
الاستضافات المتبادله على مناطق السيطره
العسكريه روسيا تواصل قصف البنيه التحتيه
الاوكرانيه دون هواده ام اوكرانيا
لتحقيق مزيد من التقدم الميداني في ظل
تراجع روسي على الارض
[تصفيق]
تراجع وكبه رصد من قبل الغرب الدائم
لاوكرانيا وسيناريوهات تطرح حول مستقبل
النزاع من قبل قاده عسكريين واستخباراتين
على راسه
مديره الاستخبارات الوطنيه
في ما يخص الاوكرانيين ضمن الاطار الزمني
الحالي
تفاؤل امريكي لصمود القوات الاوكرانيه
التي يحظى بعد عناصرها بدعم وتدريب من قبل
وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه وبيان اخير لها
يؤكد تراجع التاييد الشعبي للحرب الروسيه
اظهر مسح الرسميه
25% فقط من الروس يريدون استمرار الحرب قد
يواجه الكريم لينس صعوبه متزايده في
الحفاظ على موافقه الشعب على الحرب
توقعات غربيه قبل تعكس عناد التخطيط
العسكري الروسيه حيث اظهرت صور عبر
الاقمار الصناعيه قاعده للجيش الروسي بنيت
في مدينه
الساحليه التي تؤمنوا ممر بريا بين
القرمباس وتعطي سيطره على الساحل
الاوكراني المطل على البحر الاسود على
السمان العربيه
انتقد ميخائيل بود يولاك احد كبار مساعد
رئيس الاوكراني فلوج سيلنسكي
تويتر الى الماسك بسبب الحلول السحريه
البسيطه التي يطرحها الملياردير مشيرا الى
اقتراحاته بشان الغزو الروسي لاوكرانيا
والاشراف على محتوى تويتر
[موسيقى]
الاء مشاهدينا الى التقرير الرياضي مع عبد
الله درويش
[موسيقى]
عقبه السنغال نحو دوري الربع النهائي
بفوزه عليه بثلاثه اهداف من دون رد ليضرب
موعدا مع المنتخب الفرنسي في مباراه مثيره
المرتقبه وجاء هدفه الانجليزي الاول عبر
لاعب الوسط هندرسون في الدقيقه الثامنه
والثلاثين من عمر الشوط الاول يحتفل بهدف
الاول في كاس العالم قبل ان يفك اخيرا
هاري كين صيامه عن التهديد ويسجل هدفه
الشخصي الاول في هذه المسابقه والثاني
لمنتخب بلاده في هذه المباراه عند الدقيقه
الخامسه والاربعين ومنح بوكا بلاده والهدف
الثالث عند الدقيقه الثامنه والخمسين
ليؤكدته بالوصول الى الدور الثامن
[تصفيق]
وقد النجم كيليان مبابي منتخب فرنسا
للعبور الى دور ربع النهائي بعد ما سجل
هدفين في شباكه بولندا في المباراه التي
انتهت بثلاثه اهداف دون مقابل لصالح منتخب
بلاده ونجح اوليفجو لتسجيل الهدف الاول
لمنتخب فرنسا في الدقيقه الرابعه
والاربعين والذي اصبح به الهداف التاريخي
لمنتخب الديوك برصيد 52 هدفا متخطا تيري
اورلي قبل ان يضيف الكيلاني هدفين
متتاليين كان الاول في الدقيقه الرابعه
والسبعين فيما جاء هدفه شخصيه الثانيه عند
الدقيقه 90 وسجلت بولندا هدفا وحيدا عبر
ليفاندوفسكي من ركله جزاء كان في الدقيقه
التاسعه من الوقت المضاف على المضاف
وتسع البرازيل لتجنب المفاجات عندما تلتقي
امام كوريا الجنوبيه وكان المنتخب
البرازيلي قد تعرض لهزيمه مفاجاه امام
الكاميرون في الجوله الثالثه من دوري
المجموعات بينما تاهلت كوريا الى الادوار
الاقصائيه بعد تحقيقها فوزا المستحقا امام
البرتغال بهدفين مقابل هدف واحد وتعد هذه
المباراه هي الاولى بين المنتخبين في اطار
نهائيات كاس العالم
كشف تاتي مدرب البرازيل لان نيمار سيشاركم
مع المنتخب الوطني في مباراه دوري 16 لكاس
العالم لكره القدم امام كوريا الجنوبيه
الاثنين وتلقى المدافع سؤال في مؤتمر صحفي
بشان امكانيه مشاركه نيمار في المباراه
لكن التي امسك بالمايكروفون ورد بالاجابه
نعم اخذ نيمار سباقا مع الزمن حتى يكون
جاهزه عقب اصابته في الكاحل امام الصربيا
في اولى مباريات منتخب بلاده ضمن المجموعه
السابعه
لا افكر حاليا سوى بهذه المباراه واعرف ان
الخصم مرهق بعد المباريات التي لعبها
اليكساندرو لن يكون جاهزا للمشاركه ولا
يمكن التسبب بتفاقم اصابه اي لاعب ما
قدمناه خلال دور المجموعات من اداء واهداف
هو نتائج التدريبات التي خدناها على بناء
الهجمه وكيفيه الوصول الى المرمى
حل للمنتخب البرازيلي في مختلف المباريات
ونعرف نقاط القوه لديه اللاعبون يعرفون ما
هو المطلوب منهم امام فريق مثل البرازيل
مواجهه البرتغال الحقتنا بدنيا ومعنويا
ولم نتدرب لمده يومين هو حمل كبير علينا
التعامل معه بينما ارح البرازيل النجوم في
المباراه الثالثه
ويلتقي المنتخب الياباني امام نظيره
الكرواتي ضمن منافسات دوري 16 من منافسات
كاس العالم لكره القدم وخلق الساموراي
المفاجاه بتصدر مجموعته امام منتخبات
كبيره مثل اسبانيا والمانيا من جانبه بين
وصيف النسخه الماضيه كرواتيا يسعى لمواصله
مشواره في البطوله بعد ان حلف المرتبه
الثانيه خلف منتخب المغرب في المجموعه
الثالثه
عاليه الان ونؤمن بانفسنا وبامكاننا الفوز
على كرواتيا حتى الان لم تتمكن الكره
اليابانيه من الذهاب ابعد من ثمن النهائي
شاركت في اربع بطولات كاس عالم ووصلت الى
الثمن النهائي مرتين اتمنى ان نكون في
يومنا امام كرواتيا وان نكتب تاريخا جديدا
لبلادنا في النهائيات
لقد عبرنا دور المجموعات وهو وصلنا الى
دوره 16 هذا امر جيد نحن موجودون هنا
لمواجهه الصعاب سنفعل ذلك هذا حلمنا كما
تعلمون لكننا سنتخذ خطوه واحده في كل مره
نحن بحاجه الى التحلي بالصبر الاهم مباراه
اليابان وبعد ذلك سنرى اذا كنا سنذهب الى
ابعد من ذلك
كانت هذه ابرز اخبار المونديال شكرا لكم
على حسن المتابعه
افاده المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان بان
قوه النظام قصفت القاعده العسكريه التركيه
الواقعه على اطراف مدينه اعزاز في ريف حلب
وقال المرصدين القاعده الموجوده في مركز
البحث العلمي البحوث العلميه تم قصفها
براجمات الصواريخ والمدفعيه الثقيله من
قوه نظام المتمركز في قريه تلجبين في حلب
الشمالي واضاف المصدن القوات التركيه ردت
على القصف باستهداف في مناطق انتشار
القوات الكرديه وقوات النظام في ريف حلب
الشمالي كما سنه القوات التركيه وفصائل
مواليه لها قصفا بالمدفعيه ثقيله على
اطراف بلده العريمه بالقرب من قاعده
الروسيه بريف منبج الغربي شرقي حلب ضمن
مناطق سيطره قوه سوريا ديمقراطيه
حزام امنيه على الحدود مع سوريا موقف تركي
لم تتراجع عنه انقره لسنوات بل اكدته في
اكثر من مناسبه واسرار تركي قابله
انتقادتهم امريكيه فادت بان هذا الامر الى
ما تم سيتسبب في تعطيل الحرب ضد داعش
الذي تعتزم تنفيذه على حدودها مع سوريا
رغم التحذيرات الامريكيه وامكانيه دلاع
مواجهه مباشره واسعه مع القوه الكرديه في
الشمال السوري
حزام يمتد على طول الحدود مع سوريا بعمق
30 كم وتهدف انقره من خلاله لتامين حدودها
من الهجمات الارهابيه وايضا طرد المجموعات
الكرديه من الشمال السوري
ورغم تفاهمها لمخاوف الاتراك الا انا
واشنطن حذرت انقره من مغبه تعطيل عمليه
القوات الامريكيه والكرديه ضد تنظيم داعش
في سوريا
ليست هناك خصومه دائمه في السياسه هذا ما
اكده الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان عندما
تطرق الى علاقه بلاده مع سوريا في الوقت
الذي تسع موسكو لترتيب لقاء بين اردوغان
والرئيس السوري بشار الاسد الذي رفض
اللقاء ما لم تنسحب القوات التركيه بشكل
كامل من الاراضي السوريه
على الارض ازدادت التحركات العسكريه حيث
سيره القوات الامريكيه دوريات المشتركه مع
قوات الاسد واشرت قوات التحالف تدريبات في
قاعدتها بحقل كونيكو كما وصلت تعزيزات
كرديه من 600 جندي باليات ومدافع ودبابات
الى ريف حلب
مؤشرات على ان الوضع متجه نحو مواجهه
عسكريه غريبه
تنطلقوا في بروكسل محاكمه 10 متهمين في
تفجيرات مطار ومترو بروكسل التي وقعت في
مارس العام 2016 واعلنت رئيسه المحكمه
لورانس مسارت ان جلسات المحاكمه ستبدا
بتحديد الجهه المعنيه على ان يشرع ممثلون
نيابه العامه في تلاوه بيان الاتهامات غدا
الثلاثاء
في تونس قرارات الغرفه نقبيه للمؤسسات
الصيدلانيه وقف تزويد الصيدليات بالادويه
بدل من اليوم الاثنين
حلولا لانقاذ القطاع وضمان توزيع الادويه
في البلاد
الاحد هو يوم عطله في تونس تتوقفوا بموجبه
جل الانشطه في البلاد الصيدليات بدورها
تخضع لهذه القاعده ويغلق معظمها ابوابه
لكن هذه المره قد يتواصل هذا الاغلاق الى
اجل غير مسمى بسبب قرار موزعين الادويه
بالجمله ايقاف تزويد صيدليات بالادويه هذا
الاعفاء يعطى لهم من المسنات 2016 لكن سنه
2022 وزاره الماليه رفضت اعطاء هذا الوفاء
مما قد يسبب لهم حجز في السيوله الماليه
قد يتضطر 50% من هذه القطاع الى الافلاس
نقابه موزعي الادويه بالجمله تؤكد ان قرار
يعود الى عدم التواصل الى حل وعدم تجديد
شهاده خصم من المورد للمؤسسات للموزعه
للادويه بالجمله على ما بيعات الادويه
للسنه اثنتين 22
ونظرا للارتفاع المتواصل للاعباء الماليه
لهذه المؤسسات ما يتسبب في ازمه خانقه
وضعيه تضرر معها نشاط الصيادله واشتكى
منها المواطن قرار النشاط فما ضرار في همم
فريتن بتاع التزاوج ويخلينا خموف النهارين
الجايين زيد القدام نقرا حسبنا من توه مش
من نصفه نوفر والادويه المطلوبه والكل
عنه وقبل في نقص في المواد الغذائيه
الدوله الصحيه
والتي تنطلق من اهتراء البنيه التحتيه
الصحيه ولا تتوقف عند تدني الخدمات الصحيه
ونقص الادويه ما يجعل جل المرضى يكافحون
بلا سلاح ضد الامراض وخاصه الخطيره
والمزمنه منها وليد عبد الله العربيه
تونس
ونظام يعدم اكثر من 500 شخص منذ مطلع
العام
قوى سياسيه سودانيه توقع اليوم على اتفاق
الايطالي لحل الازمه وتشكيل سلطه انتقاليه
مدنيه
الحرب في اوكرانيا ويصفها بالسحر والبسيطه
دائما العربيه
[موسيقى]